90 people will give you a card for the
chiropractor but if you go i can't
function today because i just don't i'm
just not functioning and mentally i'm
just so
depressed or i can't
i can't put
i can't put two minutes together i gotta
go see a psychiatrist i would imagine
that most of the world it's kind of
frowned upon you know and unless you
have a you know i have a diagnosed
disorder now which i didn't get
diagnosed until i was in my 40s but with
ocd and depression anxiety but what
about just life why why did it take that
long because i'm old and there is a
stigma from a kid that was born in the
50s and grew up in the 60s and 70s there
is a stigma to mental illness because of
the symptoms that i had that were in
alignment with bipolar they were trauma
induced because they've been healed once
i got through my trauma so i couldn't
really have bipolar if i no longer have
bipolar symptoms bipolar is seen as a
chemical imbalance which means it is
incurable unlike a personality disorder
or something that is alterable it is so
to be diagnosed as bipolar and then to
no longer show symptoms of bipolar with
no medication consistently for two and a
half years which is where i'm at now
there's there was a little something
going on with my psychiatrist diagnosis
of me right what i've realized from
writing this book about mental health is
that humans we're really not that
complicated we like to think of
ourselves as these magical mysterious
things we're just complicated plants we
need light we need water we need oxygen
we're very connected to nature and our
you know our thoughts and feelings and
emotions they don't come from this
ephemeral place where we have no control
over how we think and feel
they're just brains reacting to signals
from our bodies you know anxiety is just
our body trying to protect ourselves
from a dangerous situation and yet how
it manifests in our modern brains is
this weird
you know terror about a social situation
you can't quite put your finger on but
when you break it down and go hey wait a
minute mental health isn't this thing
that controls my life that i was born
with it's like actually we're all just
people and machines and bodies and
biological things and we can just do
things that change how we think and feel
and for me as someone that has really
just
struggled a lot of my life with mental
health thinking i'm just broken i was
built that way sometimes i just feel bad
and there's nothing i can do about it
that's wrong
there's something you can do so people
who have real mental health problems
right bad depression um bad ptsd with
panic attacks right or any kind of post
trauma syndrome ptsd is just one of them
right so they're people of real mental
health problems right they're people who
aren't alive right and the rest of us
all have mental health issues
right i mean it's complicated to
navigate the world right it's
complicated to go forward with all the
things that happened to us right and if
someone comes in our door and they don't
have a post-trauma syndrome they haven't
made changes in their brain but they've
had issues of like this stressor or that
stressor this trauma or that trauma
right but not big enough to change the
brain well guess what that's worth
talking about too yeah right i mean i go
to psychotherapy
weekly as well and have for years and
years and and like sometimes i have
something problematic to talk about but
if not i mean my goodness there's enough
in my life
that it could help me function better so
this idea that like we can all benefit
from grounding to ourselves and what's
going on inside of us what are the
stressors and what are the decisions
that we're making absolutely and then we
can shift back and forth between having
a problem and having issues right so as
i wrote about in the book that i wrote
after my brother's suicide i had
real problems i mean my brother chose to
end his life by suicide and it deeply
impacted myself and my parents and when
i look back i had no mental health
background i was lucky that i had people
around me who were helpful and
supportive right and and helped me get
through it but you know my thoughts
about myself and whether the world was
safe enough and i could go make
something of myself and it had really
shifted realizing that it's a
complicated journey
for everyone
you know because when i was growing up i
thought like i was the only confused
person i was the only scared person i
was the only insecure person
you know i was the only person
who really was filled with doubts and
then time passes you realize oh
everybody is you know it's just
unfortunately we live in a culture
where most of us are really good at
pretending otherwise i'm as we speak i'm
medicated i'm always in therapy i've put
there what happens if you weren't on
medication
i don't think i could survive what does
that look like
uh deep dark depression and i don't you
know uh
have you ever seen like howard hughes
you know he ended up in the fetal
position naked peeing into bottles in
his room
but
that's not far from where i could be
if i was able to even stay alive you
know and i'm all kidding aside it's just
really hard every waking moment is a
battle
you know and is is is hard to uh and and
i do it by you talk about living in the
moment but i stay busy i'm not good with
downtime i'm not good with the voices in
my head i had the sense that i had
bipolar because i ticked all the boxes i
had hypersexuality
hyperspending or hyperfrugality i would
go i would swing between
impulsively spending to impulsively to
being really really like i'm not going
to park in a meter and drive around the
block 10 times to find it like i
literally i can afford a two dollar
meter i don't know why i'm tripping
i understand that sometimes you're stuck
in a cage and like you need things like
antidepressants and therapy and things
like that and like to kind of help you
yeah
but to get to a place where you
recognize that you are in control of
this and that the mind is kind of like
the secondary passenger and you need to
retrain it i mean it's it's a lot of
times i've done a lot of this stuff too
with different aspects not necessarily
depression or anxiety but other aspects
of my life of patterns that would show
up and i ended up realizing holy crap
this is my six-year-old self
yeah those profound therapy moments
you're like i'm not that cliche damn it
i am that cliche i'm just talking about
walmart my fifth birthday party it's a
human experience and this is like a lot
of people they have this idea that
mental health is just for people that
have crippling anxiety or people that
are like suicidally depressed and they
have a medical problem but mental health
is just how you think and feel at any
given moment and it's something that all
humans have so people go i don't need
therapy i don't need to read a book
about mental health because i'm fine and
it's like yeah but how stressed are you
how much do you worry in a day what is
your mindset that completely controls
your outlook on the world from how you
perform in your career how you deal with
your relationships and most importantly
on a day-to-day level how do you talk
back to the own voice in your head
because for me you know my experiences
in life i went through a lot of bullying
when i was a child i had a very
upsetting time for the first 18 years it
built me to be this very cynical
defensive person and my first instinct
the first voice that would pop up was
always that self-sabotage self-doubt and
that's not the truth and what's so
important is being able to stop
like look in the reflection of what's
really going on and think is this the
truth or actually am i kind of
sabotaging myself in this way and it's
something that every single human on
earth goes through but most people go
through their entire lives without
questioning it yeah
so much of what goes on with us like it
all goes on inside of us right and then
we we have to live with the experiences
that happen inside of us and how they
impact us which which is why we need a
health care system that's actually
paying attention to what's going on
inside of us talking to us about it
right as opposed to seeing all of us the
same i mean i think you know the the
what we've been talking about so far is
like really important right because it's
acknowledging the difference across
human beings that hey we're not all the
same right we don't have the same
genetic makeup we don't have the same
experiences we don't react the same way
and if we look at us all the same right
how are we going to help any of us and
and that's also you know in writing a
book that i i wish to be accessible to
anyone right who chooses to pick it up
and read it and entertaining and
engaging that writes about these things
in into the common plain
language right it's so that we can gain
an understanding
not just of what it is but of how do we
prevent it i mean that's ultimately what
we wish to do or how do we recognize it
if it's present how do we treat it
because the systems around us the
medical
systems and mental health care systems
um are doing such a poor job
of that and where my thoughts go and my
rituals and whatever ocd throws my way
then i can be in the deepest darkest
hole mentally that i could possibly be
in so right now i'm talking to you and i
don't know what tomorrow brings i don't
know what you know
i have no control over what happened
yesterday
and my whole career has been like that
you know i didn't plan this career i had
no idea
that you know 40 years after that dare
i'd be sitting down talking to someone
like you about what i did 40 years ago
insomnia um grandiosity
i don't know if the grandiosity went
away completely um
that one's that one's still my ego
working on that um but i ticked like
seven out of nine boxes and was
diagnosed with mild hippomania
and what bessel vanderkult talks about
in that book that you just got the body
keeps the score
is how he's fought for at that point
over 25 years with the
american psychiatrist association
to have them put in the diagnostic
statistics manual the manual that all
psychiatrists have to purchase
every couple five years or whatever it
is when they update it to put into that
book that trauma is something that
people have and that it should be looked
at when you're treating people and
giving them chemicals and putting them
in their bodies so i'm on both sides of
it i'm both grateful for the mood
stabilizer that absolutely i'm so
grateful i was on it when my memories
came back
because
i did not go into
what could have been a really horrific
downward spiral due to the instability
of the patterns of my brain at that time
but then i retrained my brain through
all of the healing modalities i began i
knew something was different i knew
something was wrong i wasn't taking care
of myself like i did before and i was
unhappy and i was depressed i was not
just unhappy i went for that to depress
it i was drinking too much and you know
and
you know i really didn't have a
knowledge of like oh you think about
yourself differently or you have an
internal dialogue that's built around
shame now and built around shock and
you know i needed help then and there's
no
shame to that right in a sense right
like trauma makes us want to feel
ashamed so that we hide it's it that's
like you know that's
the ultimate in evil right that the
thing that you need help with creates
shame that makes you hide it
right but we we absolutely need help if
it rises to the point we're not sleeping
well we're depressed we can't get it out
of our minds then we need to go and get
some
help and when we do
it can change things just like you know
if one hurts one's knee or you know one
has a problem in their lungs or like we
go see
people to help us and it's no different
i mean if you imagine
how if it's okay i'll give an example
how after certain if trauma rises to the
level of overwhelming our coping skills
right then our brain function changes
like we were talking about earlier right
and we can't just think our way into
changing that back right is this anxiety
well it gets to be it's more than just
anxiety it can manifest itself as
anxiety but there are automatic things
that go on in the brain so for example
the idea of like how do we react if we
if we're not on the other side of trauma
that's overwhelmed our coping mechanisms
when we see a new person right is we we
look at that person and we look for for
interest like do you look interested in
me do you look benign right do you look
like you might have something to offer
in a conversation right we look for
other at other people with a sense of of
curiosity right and interest in them
after trauma in the way that get
overwhelms our copings because we're
different going forward then we're
looking at other people through the lens
of vigilance mechanisms which is really
like are you do you mean me harm
right the thing about that's not it the
best way to go through
life if we're trying to like do the best
we can at our job right or people are
trying to find someone to have a
relationship with or you know whatever
it may be or even like meeting a new
neighbor if you know if we automatically
say i see you i don't know you and i
automatically thinking are you trying to
harm me right
that is so different than the kind of
openness
right that we feel
if we're not in that situation and the
idea that oh we're just going to think
our way out of it right it's just like
it's not how that works no more than if
someone has an acl pair and you think
i'm just going to look at it like this
until it fixes itself right
right so so if we recognize what's going
on inside of us and we look at what's
our internal dialogue what are we saying
to ourselves right as the day
goes along right what's our life
narrative what do i think of my life
what kind of story would i tell right
these are the ways that we start to get
in touch with what's going on inside of
us so that we can again be empowered
right like you said sovereignty or what
sometimes is called agency of like look
i've got i'm in charge of myself right
i'm an adult and i'm in charge of myself
in a world that doesn't make that easy
so my memories came back in august of
2018. by november of 2019
i went off my medication with my doctor
i told i didn't go back to my
psychiatrist because he was already
trying to like have me go on something
else the more i told him i was doing
well he was like sure that it was my
grandiosity i was trying to put me on
different things i talked to my doctor
who's an actual phd and has a background
in neuroscience and knows the brain very
well so specializing in emdr which is
specifically a treatment of the brain
right
and she said let's watch how you do
and that was
coming off of the medication finding
modalities that help me that are free
and coinciding them with treatment that
thankfully i was able to you know have
insurance pay for
but now you know on my maintenance is
every day i do that work hand on
anything else that's fine yeah i don't
know oh wait hand on hand is the problem
hand on hand on butt is okay i have
three children
i've touched things i've seen things
i've done things so do you just wear
gloves then no you need to use your
hands for some things
no hand on hand i just like after i do
that okay i don't shake your hand and go
thank you like i won't shake your hand
but i'll touch anything i think i think
we like had a slight quick embrace when
you came in right i totally forgot that
you didn't i don't remember but i would
hug you okay i would hug you oh yeah
because there she is she's flirting
again i think she's flirting again oh
man